guys date a girl that's like overweight
no no no
no
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'll put it i
apologize um um he must be apologizing
yeah no no respectfully in it but
if she's oversized like if she's over it
depends what you mean we mean my
overweight personal to your size though
yeah 100
so if she if she's like if she's you
know
obviously
yeah if she's ob yeah i wouldn't even
look in that direction
i think about i'll be thinking about
ways around it like
[Laughter]
you're like oh athletes yes i'm just
kidding i can't handle that bro
it's about what you can handle don't
know
if you can handle you know what i'm
saying
as much as they're eating
would you date a guy that's shorter than
you
no she wouldn't
[Laughter]
no i mean like if i'm i'm seeing you
guys i mean i can live with that he'll
be shorter than me hills no thank you i
want you to be able to help me how tall
is the top shelf
5'4
i want you to be able to help me like
why am i understood and you were trying
to get us through as well
[Music]
okay they help with each other
that can help me around you know what i
mean you know you know what's
interesting men are ashamed for not
dating overweight women but women will
say all day like oh he needs to make
this much money he used to be this tall
that i don't know i'll just let someone
let's not get started
let's listen like that let's not get
started let's hear it but let's let's
not know this we should i don't pay the
bills though
i'll just say height doesn't it
yeah it doesn't i mean instagram if you
have a lot of followers it does pay the
bills but vbr doesn't lie
you know anyways next question
a bbl would you guys rather have a girl
with a smaller butt that's natural
natural or a bbl 110 natural natural
natural natural because if we're growing
older now i see your your things just
melting
so why is he dripping like no way like
bro you know like girls now that you be
bills you know how much you have to go
to gym and how much you have to get
checkups bro when you're 65 you're still
going to get check-ups bro come on bro
how do you how do you know i didn't even
know this
yeah yeah more than like 5.99 oh now
bbc's
there was a female that was a youtuber
and obviously naturally she kind of had
bunda
yeah but then
she then got used her fat from her
stomach into her
what was that the liposuction yeah but
then she then got a bbo and then she
became botched but it was like
she has to go with gymnastics to
maintain it and she goes through all
these healthy conditions and that
because of it and it's like when like
obviously cool you had a few rolls in
there but it's like you could have still
went gym now you have to go jam because
you have no choice because if you don't
encourage him you're going to die what
about like what about like what about
like fake boobs is it the same
it is the same
there's a very big difference between
what you actually want and what you like
to see yeah i mean
like obviously big breasts whatever
whatever i like when you see it on the
roadway on the street
it's a brother that's holding it in
place like that
everyone you know
whatever you like yeah cool but you
don't actually want that do i mean like
when i'm at home i don't want this
blowing up in your face i don't need
that i don't want that you would want
canyon
so it depends it's a lot of what you
need versus what you just like to look
at social media change like the
perspective of what some men
looking
for girls these days i think
yeah true i think it's because we're
coming into a digital age now where a
lot of things on social media are
actually affecting their lives
it's true
i'm in the health and yeah
especially since cloven because everyone
just shifted online
because no one was outside everyone was
like one line like do you know what i
mean
it's a bit anyone remember that phase
everyone became youtubers
do you guys think that social media um
gave unrealistic standards more for men
or for women and men men men men would
you have to be a boss
yeah we have to make money in like all
that yeah definitely definitely men like
sometimes it's like oh when you get into
our argument
and he doesn't send you like 300 pounds
and he's not the one like what and the
thing is girls actually start believing
that
i actually stopped believing that like
no no we just argued
of course we would we know you would we
know do you do you feel like most girls
think they're hotter than they are
110 yes
yeah but they say no girls are bad you
know your friend is media you guessed
them as soon as you let's get into
argument or a fight you are ugly anyways
like bro
no but like
i don't know it's not in terms of like
reassurance because some guys don't need
that but if guys aren't
giving them the kind of look you know i
mean it kind of does boost a bit of
confidence
you're not going to marry a godo you
don't know that well
it's like sometimes girls we like
we we lie to each other though like i've
been to a point where i was i would say
like i was overweight right because
after college um i stopped playing
sports and it just caught up to me like
really fast and i ended up losing it but
like oh my god my friends have gassed me
up so much and i'd be like no i'm fat oh
they'll be like you're thick
that is
there'll be times that a guy could get a
trim like i could get a trim that was
the time i got a trim i was feeling it
my boy sorry you know
what the [ __ ] is that who's nicer you
know what i mean what's kinder to
someone telling them the truth or
telling them what they want to hear
i think it depends on your relationship
as well
from a distance i'm gonna tell you look
good you know but if it's my friend
friend i'm gonna take [ __ ] up like that
that dress let's pick a different one
still i feel like i fall out for guys
i feel like for guys guys can take more
criticism than girls yeah yeah they just
burn in silence yeah yeah i got a guy it
would burn the garbage they gotta move
on but if the girl now gets burned yeah
it's like what so what you're better
than me now so it still depends on the
friendship though
yeah but even some friendships some
girls can be friends for years and like
sometimes some girls they're just girls
they're just girls that just can't take
criticism so no matter how long you're
friends with someone